bonjour Cyril Bretz merci de répondre à
nos questions vous êtes spécialiste des
relations internationales à l'Institut
Jacques Delors cofondateur du blog
Eurasia prospective et puis on vous doit
notamment dix attentats qui ont changé
le monde comprendre le terrorisme au 21e
siècle séparus en octobre 2020 chez
Armand Colin
c'est l'attaque que le monde redouté
oui c'est le scénario du pire c'est le
scénario maximaliste ça n'est pas une
attaque limitée au bassin du don ça
n'est pas une attaque limitée à la zone
de la Crimée c'est une attaque sur
l'ensemble du territoire les frappes pas
aériennes vise à neutraliser les forces
armées ukrainiennes et donc la capacité
de résistance de l'intégralité de l'État
et du territoire ukrainien et
visiblement les forces russes se
rapprochent de Kiev c'est ce que disent
en tout cas les autorités
ukrainiennes ça veut dire que les
ambitions de l'ambition de Vladimir
Poutine c'est visiblement de conquérir
la capitale
écoutez c'est de la crainte que tout le
monde a attendons d'avoir des
informations de terrain confirmés ce qui
est sûr c'est ces frappes aériennes ce
qui est certain également c'est que des
mouvements de troupes se font par le
nord la Biélorussie par l'est la Russie
par le sud-est le don de basse et le et
par le sud c'est à dire la Crimée est-ce
que la Russie a les moyens d'occuper
durablement l'Ukraine
je ne sais pas en revanche ce qui est
certain c'est que le Kremlin se limite
dans ces déclarations sur la
neutralisation du gouvernement et des
forces armées ukrainiennes mais prétend
seulement des militariser et non pas
conquérir l'Ukraine on est habitué à la
distance qui peut y avoir entre les
déclarations et les actes donc je pense
qu'il faut se garder pour le moment de
conclusion sur les objectifs tactiques
aujourd'hui et dans les jours qui
viennent parlons peut-être du discours
de Vladimir Poutine qui a repris le
terme de génocide que mènerait
actuellement l'Ukraine contre les Russes
il avait déjà utilisé ce même mot lors
de la guerre en Géorgie en 2008 il veut
dit-il des nazifier l'Ukraine et est-ce
qu'il a une vision paranoïaque là
il a une vision historique tout à fait
particulière et complotiste il essaye de
justifier cette opération militaire
illégale en se référant au passé de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et aux nazis il
faut se souvenir que quand les troupes
allemandes sont entrées par l'ouest de
l'Ukraine elles ont été accueillies par
une frange de la population et par les
partis politiques les plus antis
communistes comme des libérateurs et
c'est ce qui lui sert de prétexte pour
qualifier l'Ukraine de néo-nazie il
prétend également qu'il y a un génocide
des
minorités russes et russophone en
Ukraine ça avait été le cas en Géorgie
c'est l'argument classique absurde mais
classique utilisé pour défendre les
minorités russophone dans plusieurs
états anciennement de l'URSS il a
largement distribué des passeports pour
que des citoyens russes soient présents
dans cette partie de l'Ukraine c'est
donc deux prétextes classiques attendus
et parfaitement infondé qui qui sont
brandis aujourd'hui donc quand il évoque
le droit à la légitime défense c'est
complotiste
c'est complotiste et c'est une façon de
se mettre sous la protection légale de
la Charte des Nations Unies qui prévoit
trois recours à la force à son article
51 la légitime défense l'appel à
l'intervention militaire par un état
c'est ce qui avait été utilisé en Syrie
et un mandat des Nations des Nations
Unies donc il essaye dans cet
argumentaire d'habiller d'une égalité
superficielle son intervention militaire
c'est vrai que l'histoire revient
beaucoup dans cette opération militaire
dans cette guerre pour Vladimir Poutine
la Russie aurait en quelque sorte
abandonné des cadeaux aux anciennes
républiques soviétiques il veut au fond
les réparer aujourd'hui
exactement il veut effacer certaines des
conséquences de la chute de l'URSS et il
a été très explicite depuis maintenant
15 ans sur la question c'est une
tragédie la fin de l'URSS pour lui et
les conséquences sont la colonisation je
cite encore une fois la colonisation par
l'Occident de l'ancienne URSS avec
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne et
de le temps notamment aux trois États
baltes
Victor urban le Premier ministre
hongrois est en train de s'exprimer il
condamne l'attaque russe Victor urban
qui est plutôt proche de Vladimir
Poutine qui est plutôt un allié
une autre chose Cyril Bretz dans le
discours de Vladimir Poutine il menace
ceux qui seraient tenter d'interférer
bon on imagine que il parle des
Occidentaux cela conduirait dit-il à des
conséquences que vous n'aurez encore
jamais vu il parle de quoi là de
dissuasion nucléaire c'est une allusion
directe à une menace nucléaire il veut
condamner les Occidentaux et les alliés
de l'Ukraine à regarder sans intervenir
directement militairement son invasion
de l'Ukraine vous l'avez parfaitement lu
ce sont les deux dernières lignes de son
de son communiqué de cette de cette nuit
c'est une menace il entend il menaçait
par avance les Occidentaux s'ils venait
à aider l'Ukraine autrement que
diplomatiquement
est-ce qu'il y a une possibilité que les
Occidentaux interviennent militairement
pour aider l'Ukraine non non cela a été
explicite ni les américains ni les
Européens ne sont prêts à mourir pour
Kiev et ni les Européens ni les
Américains ne sont prêts à s'engager
pour un pays qui n'est pas
officiellement leur allié l'Ukraine dans
un conflit direct avec la Russie qui a
hérité de l'URSS son statut de puissance
nucléaire voilà l'OTAN qui est au coeur
des discussions Cyril bridge vous
propose d'écouter le secrétaire général
James Stoltenberg qui s'est exprimé il y
a maintenant quelques minutes
aujourd'hui le Conseil nord-atlantique a
décidé d'activer notre plan de défense
c'est une étape prudente et défensive
pour protéger nos nations pendant cette
crise et cela nous permettra de déployer
les forces nécessaires dont les forces
de réponse de l'OTAN là où il y en a
besoin
nous avons environ 100 avions de chasse
en alerte dans le ciel pour protéger
notre espace aérien et plus de 120
bateaux en mer du Grand Nord jusqu'à la
mer Méditerranée
j'ai demandé la tenue d'un sommet
virtuel des leaders de l'OTAN demain
pour convenir de la suite
voilà Cyril Brett le secrétaire général
de l'Alliance qui annonce l'activation
des plantes défenses il s'adresse là à
qui à la Pologne à la Lituanie
d'anciennes république soviétique qui se
sente aujourd'hui menacés par la Russie
oui il s'adresse à l'intégralité de
l'Alliance ce que vous avez mentionné
évidemment mais aussi du flanc sud la
Roumanie la Bulgarie et on voit bien
tout à la fois la détermination de
yenstoltenberg le norvégien qui dirige
le temps et son impuissance puisque il
s'agit simplement d'avancer les défenses
aux limites de l'Ukraine sans y pénétrer
et donc on voit à quel point le temps
est à la fois résolu uni mais en même
temps un puissante a arrêté cette
arrêtée cette opération militaire donc
les
Ukrainiens vont affronter seuls les
Russes avec une armée qui ne fait pas le
poids
tout à fait tout à fait
vous diriez qu'on est parti pour un long
conflit ou enfin c'est difficile à dire
aujourd'hui mais qu'est-ce que ça vous
aime très difficile vous avez vous avez
raison c'est très difficile à dire nous
ne sommes pas dans la salle de
planification des forces armées russes
en revanche nous pouvons raisonner à
partir de signaux un signal assez fort
c'est que jusque début mars tous les
aérodromes civils russes
sont fermés et donc pour que l'espace
aérien soit libre et donc ça veut dire
que la Russie se prépare à pouvoir être
opérationnel militairement dans les airs
jusque début mars ça nous donne une
indication sur la longueur des
opérations et vraisemblablement aussi
sur leur nature c'est à dire que c'est
véritablement une opération de grande
ampleur qui est en cours de déroulement
je pense que nous n'en sont
malheureusement nous n'en sommes
malheureusement qu'à la première phase
militaire de cette de cette opération
est-ce il y a des comparaisons vous
faites avec ce qu'il s'est passé en 2008
et l'invasion russe en Géorgie en tout
cas ce début d'invasion est-ce que
aujourd'hui on est dans un autre degré
d'intensité oui on est dans un autre
degré d'intensité parce que les frappes
ne sont pas limitées à la bande à la
bande frontalière se sont vraiment les
centres de décision militaires puis
peut-être demain les centres de décision
civiles qui sont directement frappés en
revanche comme nous nous sommes dit tout
à l'heure il est trop tôt encore pour
savoir si la Russie prépare une
occupation ou simplement enfin
simplement ou plus spécifiquement une
opération militaire centrée sur les les
infrastructures militaires pour que
l'Ukraine soit définitivement des armées
voilà donc nous allons suivre nous
allons suivre le déroulement des
opérations la surprise joue un grand
rôle évidemment dans ces opérations
militaires il faut il faut les scruter
les analyser en revanche qu'on peut déjà
dire c'est que la Russie va rendre
l'Ukraine un gouvernable et indéfendable
pour de longues années je sais que vous
travaillez beaucoup sur la
désinformation autour de la Russie
on connaît Vladimir Poutine comme roi de
lingérence des cyberattaques ici donc
des intrusions militaires c'est aussi
une guerre hybride à laquelle on vit à
laquelle oui
c'est une guerre complète si j'ose dire
c'est une guerre qui se déroule aussi
dans le cyberespace c'est l'évidence
et c'est une guerre qui se déroule
actuellement dans le domaine médiatique
les communiquer
les communiqués de presse la
communication les réseaux sociaux de la
Russie vers l'Ukraine envoie des
messages qui sont hautement paradoxaux
qui sont la dénonciation de
l'illégitimité ou l'illégalité du
gouvernement des messages aussi pour
rassurer la population sur les
intentions de la Russie la protection
des civils c'est ce conflit se déroule à
une toute notre échelle que le conflit
géorgien et se déroule dans absolument
toutes les dimensions rtmr évidemment
cyber évidemment et médiatique c'est
également le cas en ce moment ça ne leur
rend pas moins dangereuse c'est la rend
sans aucun doute plus complète d'où
l'importance de nos envoyer spéciaux
merci Cyril Bret de nous avoir éclairé
je vous rappelle que vous êtes
spécialiste des relations
internationales à l'Institut Jacques
Delors cofondateur du blog Razia
prospective